i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
el otro día fuimos al parque cerca de la
casa de mi hija clara comilla clarita es
algo tímida para jugar con otras niñas y
niños pero vio una escena que no pudo
resistir los niños estaban jugando con
unos dinosaurios una de sus muchas
pasiones se acercó y les preguntó si
podía jugar con ellos no al principio no
le hicieron caso después volvió a
intentar les preguntó si le prestaban un
dinosaurio el niño de dos dijo mío mío
mío mientras abrazaba a los dinosaurios
y el niño de tres se apiadó y le prestó
un dinosaurio un y tratando de entender
la reacción del d2 se quedó pensando y
de repente dijo tengo una idea y le dio
al niño de dos años el dinosaurio que le
prestó el de tres y le dijo tú me vas a
decir que sientes que te estoy prestando
este dinosaurio y el niño de dos se
quedó así y a los pocos segundos le
prestó uno de sus dinosaurios y clara
con mí estaba satisfecha casi realizada
a sus cuatro años de edad y ese día me
dijo mamá cuando yo sea grande a los
ocho voy a ser maestra y yo creo que ya
lo es
y seguiremos teniendo episodios como
muchos de ustedes donde compartir es un
gran reto porque compartir no es algo
que conquistamos una vez y ya es nuestro
continuamos aprendiendo en cada paso o
circunstancia contextos y a lo largo de
toda nuestra vida cuando se despidió de
los niños en el parque les dijo
compartir te haga feliz cuando lo
invitaron este télex medellín muchas
gracias
estaba yo pensando bueno qué idea puede
revolucionar al mundo podría hablar de
alguna vacuna para cualquier virus o de
traer agua limpia a todas las personas
en el mundo o de poner un satélite que
diera internet para todos para mí esa
idea revolucionaria empieza con aprender
a compartir la idea más revolucionaria
si no se comparte de qué sirve por
ejemplo si yo tuviera esa vacuna
y no la compartiera con nadie a quién
beneficiaría la palabra compartir y es
un valor y un verbo tan antiguo y tan
vigente como nuestro lugar en el planeta
tierra compartir puede sentirse como un
objetivo curioso o incluso poco
importante para revolucionar al mundo
especialmente cuando hay tanto en riesgo
y las emociones son tan fuertes pero
mientras estamos en este proceso de re
imaginar la vida durante y después del
cobe 19 compartir tiene un rol central y
vital y porque nos interesaría aprender
a compartir en el día a día nos alegra y
facilita la vida pero también si
pensamos en los retos más grandes del
mundo han escuchado hablar de los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenibles de
naciones unidas son 17 grandes
ambiciosos y necesarios erradicar la
pobreza extrema y el hambre lograr una
vida saludable para todas las personas
equidad de género reducir las
desigualdades acción por el clima
de hecho ninguno de estos objetivos se
va a poder alcanzar sin compartir
incluso el 17 es generar alianzas para
el trabajo en equipo la única manera de
lograrlo es hacerlo juntos todo empieza
hoy aquí contigo y conmigo y con cómo
jugamos y cómo aprendemos a compartir ya
jugar para llevarlo a las siguientes
escalas desde lo que haces cada día y el
efecto que tiene en ti y en tu comunidad
en tu país y en este nuestro planeta
tierra
la solución hacerlo juntos explorando el
compartir vámonos a la parte más
primitiva o más evolucionada ustedes
creen que los animales comparten hay un
experimento maravilloso en una reserva
del congo donde estudian sin los bonobos
comparten un nuevo voluntariamente su
comida
le lleva a una mujer su comida a la
jaula el bonobo puede comerse toda la
comida solo porque no sabe si le van a
traer más después puede compartirla con
su compañero a través de la jaula o
pasarle lo que le sobre o puede permitir
que pase y que tome lo que necesite que
harían ustedes que creen que va a ser el
bonobo pues el bono abre la jaula de su
compañero lo deja entrar y que tome la
comida que necesita
nuestros parientes más cercanos los
volvemos de chimpancés comparten un
ancestro en común con nosotros y hay
muchos estudios que nos ayudan a
comprendernos la primatóloga isabel ven
que de chile estudia el comportamiento
social de los bonobos y nos cuenta que
los bonobos juegan y comparten toda su
vida mientras que los chimpancés
principalmente juegan durante su niñez y
tienen estructuras jerarquías mucho más
rígidas y de menos compartir los adultos
humanos que compartimos que compartimos
no todos compartimos no compartimos
siempre ni todo hasta la fecha se ha
demostrado que los adultos humanos
generamos la mayoría de nuestros
recursos cuando trabajamos en equipo los
adultos humanos compartimos en función
de una idea de justicia y también
gracias a la equidad y en cambio el
comportamiento de niñas y niños parece
un poco más egoísta ahora les voy a
compartir un estudio que nos ayuda a
mejor entender como niñas y niños de 3
años en adelante toman en cuenta si los
premios se obtienen o no como
consecuencia de una colaboración y esto
a su vez influye
en sí compartirán sus juguetes o
cualquier otra cosa con otras niñas y
niños es decir es un comportamiento
aprendido entonces cuando aprendemos a
compartir según el instituto max planck
de antropología evolutiva en alemania es
a partir de los 3 años que se da este
fenómeno de compartir cuando hay
colaboración es decir niñas y niños
comparten el premio el juguete o lo que
tienen cuando es el resultado de una
colaboración hacen un experimento con
dos escenarios en el primer escenario
ponen una dinámica de juego donde el
premio son unas canicas juegan juntos
colaboran logran un resultado y se
comparten las canicas equitativamente en
el segundo escenario otra vez juegan
juntos colaboran para alcanzar un
objetivo y a uno le dan más canicas que
al otro este niño que recibe más canicas
le da a parte de sus canicas al otro
como un acto de justicia cuando hay
colaboración hay un acto de justicia
cuando no hay colaboración no hay ese
deseo de justicia es decir no es que no
compartamos antes de los 3
sino que algo fascinante es que a partir
de los 3 años empezamos a entender
aprender a integrar esa noción de
justicia distributiva tener objetivos en
común nos ayuda a colaborar y a
compartir a partir de esa colaboración
esto es algo que podemos seguir
nutriendo a lo largo de toda la vida
hablando de ganar y competir versos
disfrutar y compartir ya vimos
experimentos con los bonobos donde
comparten voluntariamente su comida las
niñas y niños comparten sus canicas
cuando colaboran ahora les comparto una
experiencia personal ese día cuando
llegamos del parque a la casa clara cum
y no le prestó lo primero que su hermano
benjamín le pidió y en su lenguaje de un
año de edad y es que esto de compartir y
es algo en lo que nos podemos entrenar y
sí desde edades tempranas lo vivimos nos
puede hacer la diferencia en la vida y
en el mundo entero hay que entrenarnos
entonces desde hace 13 años me dedico de
educación para compartir una
organización con la misión de formar
mejores ciudadanos desde
a través del juego porque que creen
jugar es un vehículo maravilloso
poderosísimo para aprender a compartir
jugar y compartir son la clave para
desarrollar capacidades adaptativas
creativas que necesitamos en este mundo
de retos cada vez mayores el juego es
nuestra tecnología para adaptarnos
exitosamente a un mundo cambiante
necesitamos jugar y al jugar compartir
experiencias preocupaciones alternativas
posibles y construir nuevas realidades
entonces cómo podemos fomentar estos
espacios de colaboración donde niñas y
niños todos los días
aprenden a compartir jugando imaginen
juegos colaborativos seguidos una
reflexión donde compartes lo que piensas
y se va construyendo lo que piensas lo
que sueñas lo que haces en todos
nuestros juegos el compartir es esencial
y nos lleva a generar acciones que nos
trascienden acciones que tienen que ver
con esos objetivos de desarrollo
sostenibles para beneficiar al mundo
buscamos que niñas y niños
los contextos se unan jueguen y
compartan para generar iniciativas en
torno a estos grandes retos desde su
comunidad aquí va un ejemplo de uno de
nuestros juegos se acuerdan de los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible vamos
a tomar por ejemplo el número 13 acción
por el clima nuestro juego se llama el
baile del calentamiento global imaginen
una foto donde ven que niñas y niños se
suben a unos a otros y se cargan unos a
otros les cuento por qué el baile del
calentamiento global simula una isla
donde pueden refugiarse y esta isla está
representada por un aro en el piso o un
círculo hecho con hits va subiendo el
nivel del mar y tienen que buscar la
próxima isla donde refugiarse primero
van solos cada quien se empujan y solo
se preocupan por sí mismos en un segundo
momento volvemos a jugar pero ahora
agarrados de la mano de una compañera o
compañero ahora somos 12 esto genera que
ahora busca una isla preocupándome no
solo por mí misma ni solo por la persona
que tengo agarra de la mano sino también
por las otras parejas
fíjense qué diferencia hay entre
decirles niños tenemos que cuidar el
medio ambiente a tener una vivencia una
experiencia donde nos quedamos sin tener
donde poner los pies porque nuestra isla
se nos acaba lo que necesitamos es
sentir y venir para que podamos valorar
nuestra naturaleza en toda la extensión
de la palabra para que la queramos
cuidar para que la apreciemos y le
entendamos
para que entendamos todo lo que
significa después de haber compartido
estos juegos cuando preguntamos que van
a ser niñas y niños desde el día de hoy
regina una niña de 10 años hizo una
campaña para cuidar el agua en su
comunidad meses después cuando presentó
la acompaña su campaña a la comunidad
dijo esta es la primera vez en mi vida
que me siento útil imagínense si todos
aprendiéramos desde chiquitos que se
siente ser útiles y compartir soluciones
para nuestra comunidad y para nuestro
mundo para lograr esto primero
compartimos con maestras y maestros y a
su vez ellos comparten con sus
estudiantes con mamás y papás les
presento al profe víctor manuel antes de
la formación docente el profe víctor
manuel nos decía pero como que ustedes
me van a enseñar a mí yo tengo 40 años
de docencia y a través del juego
y entonces le rogamos que nos diera la
oportunidad y este es su testimonio
después de la capacitación recrear el
sentido completo del ser humano
así primero compartimos con maestros y
maestros y ellos a su vez comparten con
sus estudiantes y juegan con ellos
regresemos entonces a nuestros amigos y
parientes los bonobos primates
maravillosos de quienes tenemos tanto
tanto que aprender quiénes juegan y
comparten toda su vida niñas y niños
comparten siempre que hay una
colaboración de por medio yo ya les
compartí como a través de los juegos
colaborativos compartimos mientras nos
divertimos la pasamos muy bien y traemos
soluciones al mundo a quién de nuestros
parientes nos queremos parecer a los
bonobos que juegan y comparten toda su
vida oa los chimpancés que solo juegan
de niños
abracemos este regalo evolutivo mientras
redescubrimos nuestra creatividad y
capacidad de compartir
mi hija clara cum y les dijo a los niños
cuando se despidió en el parque comparte
te hará feliz
juega más
[Música]